сьогодні наріжте та поінформування easy
сторони студентів того що велося по
світло і вимагаю
реформування цілі ікла порізів
ціни піднести студентів but i
конкурентів паперовими у світі що
спіткають їх туя nuvi розумом і сам цьому
на засіданні раді рак три вищі
початкових за загинув по 3 4 ревнив
акредитації полтавську в регіоні та
cavid у лосево 17 лютого 2013 року
на базі полтавського національного
технічного університету імені Юрія
кондратюка були запитані голови органів
студентського літаками області на
порядку дивного засідання було харчування
щось про оборону проект у закон
україни про вашу свиту
зареєстровані Верховна Рада
україни за номером та 1187
1287 drip один 1187 grip 2
на засіданні взяв і участь заступник
голови полтавської обласної державної
адміністрації олександр коваль ви
допомогою обидва віскі директора департаменту
свитої науки обласної державної
адміністрації світла горбань його
ректори вищих початкових закладів
полтавської області
голова ради лекторії у вищих початковий
заході в 3 4 ревниво прилітати і
полтавського регіону ректор полтавського
національного технічного університету
імені Юрія Кондратюка
доктор економічних наук, професор
Володимир Онищенко by dmitry
liqui moly
предметом оговтався багато в чому
трилер
поліграфія
земноводні заклад студентки
спочатку
будемо часто
можна, можливо
але
початковому
у нас і росла і тут не води та дружина
на сьогоднішній
перевірю він
уляна
це про нього не треба буде
програми
я і цілодобово
без
lyceum шикарно антонів частина його завтра
якушкіна установки
диски
вони вчаться
на початку цуценята глядач п'ятірки сума
не буде
на
на ном
щеня
і
мій на сьогоднішній день якого ще
зазвичай
і
і спочатку
виступаючий видами та студентів доступні
голови всеукраїнської студентської ради
при міністерстві про святі науки
маладетто спорту України голова прав
кому студентик то аспірантки у контенті
у нього риба означає, що у кухаря
незареєстрованих верховною радою
україни законопроекті право ще кольору
виду волосся на всіх студентських
гривнях у загоню чипсьi пропозиції ще
над підлий вигляд органі в студентському
самоврядування області та він лівими
dmitry у навчанні 6 студентських лідерів
Петро i might закону проект за номером
за редакцію народних депутатів сировини
Ківалова
уроки йоги в мисці час створення ректор
найвищого початкового за рік українського та
дочка нас там чудово академія в'ячеслав
чекан
на волосся вно тому що з у приватних умовах
органи студентського у два дні по
ви не позичаєте diet is адміністрацію за
кладу на правах партнеру ще й
перетворюється на проект закону України
має рацію ще почет за но мару 1187
людей при суть не на засіданні ректори
вищих начальник за кладемо області так
вже ви слова лапід ринку проекту закон
україни про вашу почет за номером 1187
в результаті засідання було прийнято
рішення Петро і мати проект закон України
про ще свиту які б поза сценою на
рожевий це верховної ради
україни в Москві коня народними
депутатами України Сергієм Ківаловим
григорієм до литників там екологи широку
за номером 1187
разом пропозиції щодо даного проекту
народ років з першого засідання
заради рик перрі у полтавського сумського то
харківському районі а то на tesla ти про
позиції для законопроекту до
міністерства святі наукою маладетто
спорту України автором законопроекту
профільному комітету Верховної Ради
України